all right we got hulk brazilian soccer
player oh yes
got his
ex-wife's niece pregnant whoa and he's
having a child and uh he's now he's now
dating his ex-wife's niece
ex-wife's
yeah now on the surface this looks crazy
mark
there's more to it so basically hulk is
like he's this brilliant brazilian
soccer player like legendary dude good
yeah he was sick especially back in the
day he's now in like a i think he's
playing like a lower level slam league
if he's even still playing but he was a
legend back in the day and he was
married to this woman he's 34 now
his wife her ex-wife is 52. oh
so she got him so they've been together
a long time and he says the article is
so funny he has like some all-time
legendary quotes but he says in the
article like
yeah i only married her because we got
pregnant like i lived mostly like a
single life you know like we had
multiple kids after that because i
wanted to have children i love my family
but uh our relationship was not exactly
you know full of love it was sort of uh
you know more like diplomatic than that
and we were together 12 years and then
we split in like 2017 2018.
and then he maintains that like one he
had like side girls the whole time he
said that he's like yeah i was just like
[ __ ] whoever she knew she didn't care
like she was getting money like blah
blah uh he has this quote where he's
like
ultimately
oh i gotta pull it up specifically okay
he says i had co i had countless reasons
i spent my entire marriage betraying
iran his wife
she lived a single life she just wanted
to have the status of wife of the hulk
so he's like you just want to be my wife
that's fine i'll bankroll everything and
live my life so they split and then he
gets with his wife's sister's daughter
which is wife's sister's daughter yeah
so his wife's niece or his ex-wife
sneeze yeah which seems crazy but she's
32. also he got a type like yeah exactly
respects the bloodline yeah you gotta
check the pedigree you know what i'm
saying you get a pit bull from a
specific dealer yeah you gonna run it
back if you like that pip i want a
champion show dog let's go i got a
golden doodle they said it was gonna be
15 pounds and 40 pounds yeah well i'm
not going back yeah yeah i'm not going
bad yeah but that's a great dog i
absolutely love the dog yeah just like
its name it's a little too much yeah you
know what i mean you can't have two
sometimes you have too much wasabi
that's true you know what i mean it is
and it burns yeah so with the hulk he
recognized listen this girl got some
good genes i was plugging this girl up
until she was in her mid-40s like this
is legit
so now i got the young thang who's not
even that young compared to him he's 34
she's 32 is the same age i mean he's a
soccer star yeah and he's dating a 32
year old yeah
it's a maniac
this is an absolute maniac yeah right
like is this some kind of like german
nazi sign experiment that's going on
with these layers i mean there's
something going on for you it must be
right
so understand he dates a 52 year old and
now he just drops it down to 32.
i mean he seems like a world of
difference for him well he likes older
women i think say what he likes older
women
so he was with this girl 12 years
he married her i mean if she's 52 now he
married her when she was 40.
and he was like 22. come on b he likes
older women that's his title so he's
like yeah i'm gonna give him a 32 year
old to him that's young 32 is probably
young for him yeah he's not ready for
all that energy and [ __ ]
you're just thinking of your dog
[Laughter]
he likes he's got the walker all the
time even in the rain
god damn it
dude i'm telling you to hulk bro the
hulk maybe that's what the hulk needs
though hulk smash no if he if he got the
big guy he needs a nice weathered slit
because
listen if he got the hulk if he got this
if he got the soup heavy himself i mean
he's a thick one he needs a nice
weathered slit this kid is thick
yeah why he got he's a wide neck he's
probably got a big dick he's probably
got a big dick yeah let's just be honest
about what it is he's probably big
[ __ ] okay brazilian big dicks big
brazilian dick yeah big brazilian dick i
actually don't think they have big dicks
i think they have small dicks that's why
they're so like boastful and arrogant
what really yeah dude i mean if you
actually had a big dick you wouldn't
have like your name just be one name
you know you're trying to overcompensate
for a small dick i don't know to me it's
like yeah you know my name the hulk
have you heard that adam sandler joke
about uh trying to see shaq's dick oh in
the shower yeah
so they were on like set they were doing
a movie together you know a sailor plays
like a basketball during the movie make
sure there's always a half court so that
the guys can play when they're not
filming and shaq was playing with him
and then they went to go shower so they
could go do the film and uh so uh adam
sandler goes into the shower to look at
his dick he's like i have to go see
shaq's penis like so i have to choose
shaq's penis if i have the opportunity i
got to see shaq's penis and he goes into
the shower to look at shaq's penis and
um
shaq's bodyguard stops him and he's like
what are you doing and he goes
i just want to see shaq's penis
and he goes uh
he goes i am shaq's penis
the bodyguard
but was that a bit or that was a real
story
it was a real story he talked to shaq's
penis
he had a conversation with his actual
penis yeah no no i know that but i mean
i thought he i was wondering if he
actually tried to go see his body
because you do want to know what his
dick looks like so that's the thing it's
completely understandable it's extremely
relatable dove
what's up so he calls himself shaq
diesel there's no way his dick is
massive
is it no i think it's objectively
massive but proportionately not as big
as you'd expect who's got a huge dick
but we have first we know for a fact has
a huge ron jeremy does even that's big
dick is it that big not that big like
jeremy doesn't have a big dick i don't
get a big it's not like
is it that it's like girthy i don't know
if i've ever seen him do porn
i just know he does it i've never seen
that he's worked you've seen him you've
seen i've met him in real life but i
don't know if i've ever seen him do porn
then we just took a peek did you you
didn't go to the shower while you wanted
to i want to i want to i didn't want to
okay but back to what we're saying
yeah i don't
is there anything more to this story
uh no other the fact that they're having
a child and it's with his knees and all
the service looks crazy i think family
reunions are going to be
are they failing convenient convenient
yeah he's like christmas is convenient
yeah everybody already know he was out
there [ __ ] yeah i mean kept in the
family out of respect that's what's up
yeah i think that's the honorable thing
to do look i wonder if there's like a
brazilian like the cultural thing
happening here you incest
they're about you think they just [ __ ]
each other yeah do you think there's
some amazonians well it's actually not
incest if it's not his niece it's
someone else's
everyone's [ __ ] someone's niece well
he's [ __ ] his niece
it's not ancestral but he is [ __ ] his
niece
it's his niece too well it's his
ex-wife's niece now it's ex-wife before
his ex-wife his former niece it was his
former niece he's [ __ ] his former
niece [ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ] his former
niece dude yeah he's used to being he's
kind of lit
is it lit yeah for a brazilian
what does that mean brazil yeah it's
like yeah they just be [ __ ] up your
people [ __ ] the family a lot
what is what is that like to you what
are the rules there yeah please respect
that i'm
sephardic
oh is that an ashkenazi thing to do
cannot confirm or deny but all i know is
we don't do that we don't do that i mean
it works out for the ashkenazis if they
never let that happen aren't they the
highest iq people in the world what
ashkenazis no
yeah they're the highest iq no they've
made the test
what's on the test like how many nights
are there a hanukkah like no it's just
objective tests oh it's not jewish
things on the test but there's other
things on the test that are specific to
them like what uh do you have a hard
time breathing through your nose
that's a question yeah and then you say
yes and you get some points
i don't know if that's true that is true
bro for real i don't know i i haven't
taken it i don't know it's true man
that's on the iq there's a lot of
[ __ ] racism in that on the iq test
yes
say again the jewish supreme supremacy
bro if you make the test obviously
you're gonna do the best in it right
somebody's got to make the test
yes or no it's not a robot making it
just as human beings making it someone
someone has to there's a reason why
women don't do well on it they don't
make the test
yeah they were making the test to be
other women [ __ ] like what i don't know
how was your day
you know
there'd be something in it that's like
super woman friendly and they do really
well but they don't they've got math and
[ __ ] reading comprehension reading
comprehension read this story tell me
what happened you're like
i can't do it it's too much s.a.t is
nearly impossible al did you just bring
up a picture with both of them in the
same picture yeah i mean they look
identical he just ran it back yeah he
just really all he did he ran that [ __ ]
back this guy's a [ __ ] genius
he was just hanging out at the family
reunion looking at which niece was going
to grow into his wife yeah and he's like
it's that one i got an eye i think he's
busy i think he's so busy he's like
where am i going to meet a nice girl and
his
probably his sister is like i know
someone actually really committed
and they allow cheating in this family
this is the perfect family yeah
you gotta love it you gotta absolutely
love it okay okay i mean i feel good
about this story yeah i feel i feel good
that we even spoke about it
i feel great about this
were you feeling weird about it before i
was feeling well before because my girl
has only got brothers so uh
so if you wanted to run it back you have
to be like oh it's niece that's right
that's right it's brother sister okay
yeah ooh i don't even think about that
this guy's a monster
how long has he married his name is
larry the whole world literally monster
yeah wait a minute so how long so he
knew the girl he was married for 12
years oh no he met her when she was 20.
yes it's kosher it's not even woody
allen
you